[موسيقى]
متحف المركبات الملكيه واحد من اهم
المتاحف النوعيه في العالم ويعرض عربات او
مركبات اسره محمد علي الذي حكم هو واولاده
منذ بدايات القرن التاسع عشر وحتى قيام
ثوره يوليو
[موسيقى]
عربه الاي خصوصي عربه كلش خصوصي كل مركبه
هنا لها نوع واستخدام خاص بها 44 مركبه
شهدت على احداث ومناسبات من تاريخ مصر على
مدار قرن منها مناسبات سعيده مثل الالاي
الخصوصي التي استخدمت في فرح الملك فاروق
كما خصصت عربات للمناسبات الحزينه مثل هذه
العربه التي نقلت جثمان سعد زغلول
[موسيقى]
هذه العربه كانت هديه من الامبراطور
الفرنسي نابليون الثالث وزوجته
الامبراطوره اوجني للخديوي اسماعيل
بمناسبه افتتاح قناه السويس
تتميز العرب الهديه بدقه صناعتها والزخارف
التي تزينها من الخارج كما استخدمت في
افتتاح البرلمان عام 24
اما العرب الكلش الخصوصي استقلها
الامبراطور نابليون وزوجته اثناء الاحتفال
بافتتاح القناه
المتحف يلقي الضوء ايضا على اهتمام الملوك
في ذلك الوقت بالخيول والفرسان ودقه
التفاصيل ومنها لوازم واكسسوارات الخيول
وملابس الامراء والعاملين في مصلحه
الركائب التي اسسها الخديوي اسماعيل
مركبات كانت في يوم من الايام ركن اساسيا
في معظم الاحتفالات الملكيه الرسميه في
مصر اصبحت الان قطعا اثريه تحكي للزوار
جزءا من تاريخ مصر الحديث سمر بشات لصباح
العربيه من القاهره
[موسيقى]